Peggy's 16 hello everyone welcome back
to Mars in the sci-fi action RPG de
Technomancer we've previously covered
many aspects of the game in our gameplay
trailer today we'll go into more details
about one of them companions who will
explore and fight alongside you during
your journey all companions in the
Technomancer have their own story you
will meet some of them early while
others will not join your group until
later in the game once you get to know
them and they get to know you some will
join you out of loyalty and others out
of mere opportunity or as a result of a
chain of unfortunate events you you are
driving get us out of Oakland when
you're out there exploring or fighting
you may select two companions in your
party to come with you
choose carefully as they will all have
their own fighting skills components of
yours but also if your relationship is
good special talents increasing your
efficiency in various domains such as
drafting knowledge in Sciences or
locking all of your companions have
their own mood preferences and moral
code if you act too much against their
beliefs they might get mad at you and go
so far as to mental ruins [ __ ] murder
on the contrary shine and prove worthy
of their trust and you'll nurture
friendships or more companions who like
or love you will be more useful than
those who loathe your companions all
have their own agendas or preoccupations
ask you to help offer favors should you
decide to access their requests they
will begin their narrative arcs someday
I will kill that madman the series of
multiple quests you have gone too far to
fight someone your own size they will
let you learn much more about their past
improve your relationships and will
eventually leave a big mark on the
character and the world as you complete
these arcs and sometimes drastically
improve their efficiency in battle your
companions level up alongside you
increasing their effectiveness in combat
however they'll be left behind if you
don't upgrade their equipment companions
have their own inventory you can change
their equipment at any moment everything
you can wear they can also wear so make
sure to regularly provide them with
better armor and weapons you're also
able to upgrade their current gear
thanks to your crafting talent to
improve their effectiveness
you'll graphically increase their
survivability and enough allottee and
you can also make sure they look
appropriately badass to stroll with you
around the deadly place that is Mars
forged the destiny of Mars in the
Technomancer June 28th on ps4 Xbox one
and PC
you